POLITICAL ARSONISTS WHO FANNED
THE FLAMES.
WE WILL NAME NAMES LATER.
FIRST THE FALSE ALLURE OF
VICTIMOLOGY.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: AFTER SEEING STRONG
REACTIONS TO LAST NIGHT'S SHOW
ABOUT HOW UNIVERSITIES ARE
BREEDING GROUNDS FOR VICTIMHOOD
AND MANUFACTURED ANGER, WE
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
EXPAND ON THIS THEME TONIGHT.
GIVEN TODAY'S DEVELOPMENTS ON A
NUMBER OF STORIES, THIS
CONVERSATION WE WILL HAVE "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" TONIGHT IS MORE
PERSON THAN EVER.
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
CHICAGO POLICE WAS OUTRAGED BY
WHAT HIS DEPARTMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY ENDURED BECAUSE OF
JUSSIE SMOLLETT'S FABRICATED
HATE CRIME
>> WHEN WE DISCOVERED THE
MOTIVE, IT MADE EVERYBODY MAD.
WE HAD TO INVEST VALUABLE
RESOURCES.
WHEN Y'ALL PUT THINGS OUT THERE,
INTO THE UNIVERSE THAT IS NOT
ACCURATE FACTS, IT CAUSES US TO
HAVE TO CHASE ALL OF THAT STUFF
DOWN.
THOSE ARE RESOURCES AND TIME
SPENT THAT WE WILL NEVER GET
BACK.
>> Laura: THAT'S ALL WELL AND
GOOD, BUT POOR JUSSIE SMOLLETT.
MAKING A BOAT LOAD OF MONEY PER
YEAR.
HE WAS DRIVEN TO THIS BY HIS
WARPED VIEW OF CELEBRITY INCOME
INEQUALITY.
>> THIS ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY
RECOGNIZES THAT THE "EMPIRE"
ACTOR JUSSIE SMOLLETT TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THE PAIN AND ANGER
OF RACISM TO PROMOTE HIS CAREER
AND LIE.
THE STUNT WAS ORCHESTRATED BY
SMOLLETT BECAUSE HE WAS
DISSATISIFIED WITH HIS SALARY.
>> Laura: WHAT DROVE SMOLLETT A
SUPPORTING ACTOR ON THE FOX SHOW
"EMPIRE" TO THINK THIS VICTIM
NARRATIVE THAT HE WAS ASSAULTED
BY MAGA HAT WEARING THUGS WOULD
GIVE HIM A PAY RAISE?
THERE HAS BEEN A LONG LINE OF
CELEBRITY VICTIMS.
PEOPLE KNOWN ONLY FOR THEIR
SELF-PROCLAIMED VICTIMHOOD.
THERE WAS COLIN KAEPERNICK WHO
CLAIMED HE WAS VICTIMIZED BY NFL
OWNERS WHO WERE KEEPING HIM FROM
PLAYING JUST BECAUSE OF HIS
ACTICISM.
>> BELIEVE IN SOMETHING EVEN IF
IT MEANS SACRIFICING EVERYTHING.
DON'T ASK IF YOUR DREAMS ARE
CRAZY.
ASK IF THEY ARE CRAZY ENOUGH.
>> Laura: HE GOT A
MULTI--MILLION DOLLARS NIKE
CONTRACT AND A HEFTY NFL
SETTLEMENT.
SO YOU SEE?
VICTIMHOOD PAYS.
THEN OF COURSE THERE WAS
CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD WHO TURNED
ON THE DRAMA FOR THE KAMALA
HARRIS.
-- CAMERAS.
EVEN WHEN HER CHARGES DID NOT
HOLD WATER SHE WAS INVITED BY
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED" TO BE
AWARDS PRESENTER.
>> I AM HONORED TO SPEAK ABOUT A
WOMAN I ADMIRE SO MUCH.
RACHAEL.
I WILL ALWAYS BE INSPIRED BY
YOU.
>> Laura: IT'S OBVIOUS FOR
ANYONE CAPABLE OF OBJECTIVE
THOUGHT, IF YOU ARE A LIBERAL
AND YOU HAVE AN OUTRAGEOUS CLAIM
THAT IMPLICATES CONSERVATIVE OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU WILL
PROBABLY GET NATIONAL ATTENTION.
YOU WILL GET HIGH-PROFILE
INTERVIEWS.
YOU WILL BE ON MAGAZINE COVERS.
AND OF COURSE, YOU GET A LOT OF
MONEY.
CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD MADE OUT
LIKE BATMAN RAKING IN OVER
$800,000 THROUGH A GO FUND ME
ACCOUNT FOR HER SECURITY.
FOR A TRUMP HATING MINOR
CELEBRITY LIKE JUSSIE SMOLLETT,
THE LESSON WAS LEARNED.
VICTIM HOOD PAYS AND OFTEN
HANDSOMELY.
CRYING RACISM WOULD BE HIS CLAIM
TO FAME AND FORTUNE.
IT BEATS PLAYING SECOND FIDDLE
ON A SHOW WHOSE RATINGS WERE
GOING DOWN.
SO HE DECIDED TO WRITE HIS OWN
NEW ROLE ABOUT A MORAL CRUSADER
WARNING THE COUNTRY ABOUT THE
DANGEROUS OF TRUMP.
THE ABSURD DETAILS OF THIS
PHONEY ATTACK CONFIRM THE WORST
OF THE LEFT WINGAGAINST TRUMP.
IT LOOKED LIKE 1955 IN
BIRMINGHAM.
LIKE A BAD SPIKE LEE FILM.
THEN WHEN THE FANTASY CAME
CRASHING DOWN AND POLICE
DISCOVERED THE REAL TRUTH, THE
PAIR OF BROTHERS BUYING
SUPPLIES, THE EVIDENCE WAS
OVERWHELMING THAT SMOLLETT
COMMITTED FRAUD ON AMERICA.
SO SMOLLETT'S MEDIA COOPERATIVES
BLAMED CONSERVATIVES.
>> WE ARE GOING TO SEE
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA PLAY THIS UP
A BIT.
>> SEAN HANNITY WILL EAT JUSSIE
SMOLLETT'S LUNCH EVERY SECOND.
TUCKER CARLSON WILL EAT JUSSIE
SMOLLETT LUNCH AND THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WILL EAT
HIS LUNCH.
>> Laura: UNREAL.
HEADS THEY WIN AND TAILS WE
LOSE.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE GUILTY NO
MATTER WHAT.
NO MATTER HOW EGREGEOUS THE
FRAUD.
TODAY'S DEMOCRATS CLINGED TO
THIS NARRATIVE WITH A POLITICAL
DEATH GRIP.
HOW CAN THEY CONVINCE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO BETTER, BE BETTER
OFF AND HAVE THEIR WAGES LIFTED
UP BETTER OR THEY WILL HAVE THE
NEIGHBORHOODS SAFER AND CARTELS
WILL BE KEPT OUT OF THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND GANG MEMBERS
AND MS-13 WILL BE OUT OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
DEMOCRATS WILL BE BETTER AT
TRUMP CREATING JOBS.
THEY CAN'T ARGUE ANY OF THAT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO SUBSTANTIVE
ARGUMENTS.
BUT THEY CAN AND DO SELL VICTIM
HOOD.
FOR THAT THEY HAD A LOT OF
BUYERS.
THIS IS HOW KANYE WEST PUT IT IN
TWEETS.
THERE WAS A TIME WHETHER SLAVERY
WAS A TREND AND APPARENTLY THAT
TIME IS STILL UPON US.
NOW IT'S A MENITALITY."
THEN HE WROTE,
SELF-VICTIMIZATION IS A DISEASE.
YOU BET IT IS.
BECAUSE WHEN ANY OF US CLING TO
VICTIMHOOD, WE GIVEAWAY OUR
POWER.
OUR POWER TO SOLVE PROBLEMS AND
TO BETTER OURSELVES THE
OLD-FASHIONED WAY.
IT'S THROUGH HARD WORK.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
LEFT'S STRATEGY HERE.
THEY WILL USE FABRICATED TALES
TO DIVERT ATTENTION FROM OTHER
INCONVENIENT TRUTHS.
SMOLLETT CRASHED IN AND TOOK THE
FOCUS OFF THE VIRGINIA GOVERNOR
WEARING BLACK FACE AND FAIRFAX
WAS ACCUSED BY TWO WOMEN OF
SEXUAL ABUSE.
AND THE MEDIA JUMPED ON THE
STORY OF THE WHACKED OUT
COASTGUARD LIEUTENANT THAT
WANTED TO MURDER DEMOCRATS.
>> THIS IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS
ENCOURAGEING.
>> WORDS ARE CHEAP TO HIM BUT
THEY HAVE COSTS ELSEWHERE.
>> WE KNOW THE RECENT HISTORY OF
VIOLENCE PROPELLED IN SOME PART
BY THE PRESIDENT'S RHETORIC.
>> Laura: THIS IS SO
PREDICTABLE, IT'S ALMOST BORING.
NOTICE WHEN CONSERVATIVES ARE
TRULY VICTIMIZED, PHYSICALLY
ATTACKED, WHICH CONSERVATIVES
ARE TARGETED AND SHOT FOR THEIR
POLITICAL BELIEFS, LIKE
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE, THE
MEDIA HAS NO TIME FOR THAT.
NANCY PELOSI ADMONISHED
REPUBLICANS AGAINST LAYING BLAME
ON DEMOCRATS FOR THAT ATTACK.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GO INTO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IN TERMS OF THE LANGUAGE HE HAS
USED.
WHEN YOU HAVE ALL OF THE
ASSAULTS MADE ON HILLARY CLINTON
FOR THEM TO BE SO SANCTIMONUOUS.
IT DOESN'T USE TO BE THIS WAY.
SOMEWHERE IN THE '90s, IT WAS A
POLITICS OF PERSONAL DESTRUCTION
GOING AFTER THE CLINTONS.
>> Laura: CONSERVATIVES DIDN'T
RUSH TO CONNECT THE VERMONT
SENATOR TO THE SHOOTING.
NOR DID THEY TRY TO LINK
SMOLLETT'S CRIMINAL ACTIONS TO
HIS POLITICAL HEROES.
BARACK OBAMA AND MAXINE WATERS.
TO LINK THEM WOULD BE UNFAIR AND
STUPID.
MANY ANTI-TRUMP PARTISANS
CONNECT DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS TO A STORY THAT WAS
LUDICROUS FROM THE GET GO.
>> WHAT HE SAID HAPPENED TO HIM
FIT IN WITH A REALITY FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY SINCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS INAUGURATED.
>> YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT JUST
HAPPENED TO JUSSIE SMOLLETT IN
SOMETHING, UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE
RACISM GERMINATING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> IF YOU ARE IN A POSITION OF
POWER AND YOU HATE PEOPLE AND
YOU WANT TO CAUSE SUFFERING TO
THEM, WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL
HAPPEN?
PEOPLE WILL BE BEATEN ON THE
STREETS.
>> Laura: THE MODERN DEMOCRATIC
MOVEMENT HAS ABANDONED THE
OPTIMISM AND IDEALISM OF JOHN
KENNEDY.
NOW THEY PEDAL NON-STOP ANGER
AND RESENTMENT.
WHEN A DECADE, THEY HAVE DONE
FROM HOPE AND CHANGE TO HATE AND
RAGE.